each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the research visiting speaker series my
name is Kim rickets and I'm happy to
welcome everyone here on to speak to
research we have a bunch of great people
coming up and we're going to start
listing those on the website the
research website so you can see going
forward I know that most of you are here
because you get the invitations and the
announcements but I thought it might be
good to know moving forward who we've
invited to research today we get to hear
from Scott Rosenberg and Scott is the
co-founder of salon calm where he began
by serving as the technology editor and
then the managing editor and he is now
vice president for new products he's
written for a variety of other journals
as well this book is fascinating his new
book is dreaming in code as you see
right here and I'm just going to read
you a little excerpt by way of
introduction because i think this this
sets it up pretty well our civilization
runs on software yet the art of creating
software continue to be a dark mystery
even to the experts never in history
have we depended so completely on a
product that's so few know how to make
well there is a big and frightening gap
between our accelerating dependence on
software systems and the steady but slow
progress and our knowledge of how to
make them soundly it's an interesting
story he picks a single software plan to
tell the story and I'll let him describe
it better so please welcome Scott Rossum
Thank You Kim and thank you all for
coming out today going to give you a
little just a little overview of the
talk I'm going to tell you a little bit
about myself and dreamy encode the book
Donald Knuth says software is hard why
is that talk a little bit about
communication and miscommunication
groups of people making software and
then some time for questions oh excuse
me who's there that's good get in
anyway so I assume that I'm talking to a
room full of developers here but I
realized that may not be the case and
I've learned to adopt the test driven
approach so can I just get a sense of
how many of you are developers okay
maybe half that's good we'll have a good
good mix now my first confession is that
i am not a programmer the last time that
i wrote code that was anything more
complicated than an HTML page or messing
around with blog templates was about 30
years ago now i did learn basic back
then and there is this quote that some
of you may know from Edgar Dykstra
programming pioneer so that basically if
you learn basic you are mentally
mutilated beyond hopes of regeneration
as a programmer now some developers I
talked to agree with this others
disagree but my case I think he was
probably right now there was a game that
I loved called sumac as when i was a
teenager in the 1970s they were giving
out free accounts at nyu at the physics
building in greenwich village and we
would go and spend hours writing new
subroutines for this game sumera it was
sort of like a primitive ascii bastes
SimCity and I would sit there right in
subroutines and strange things would
happen to my sense of time I'm sorry
that I would I would emerge blinking
hours later and I would wonder you know
how much time had passed I had entered
this state of the psychologist called
flow and that was it was pretty cool but
as for what I was accomplishing this is
a code that I wrote back then this is
the only extant scrap of my programming
code there was no less than sign I was
writing on a typewriter an olivetti
portable typewriter and there was no
delete key as you can see so I don't
know this is not even really what you
would call spaghetti code this is sort
of like I don't know you could call it
gruel or something so I became a writer
and an editor and I worked for years at
the San Francisco Examiner as a theater
and movie critic I always had this sort
of closeted geek side too and I noticed
in the early 90s that the world of the
Arts that I covered in the world of
geekdom were sort of converging and I
started writing about that too then the
web came along and I immediately knew it
was where I want it to be as a kid I
published mimeograph gaming magazines
and you can tell this is mimeograph
because of the bleed-through and uh
self-publishing I loved and when the web
came along I thought this is really the
same thing only without all the folding
and the collating and the stapling and
the stamp licking I loved it so I joined
a group of colleagues from the examiner
we left the paper together in 1995 and
we started salam now at the start we
were really only vaguely aware that
running a website might actually involve
some technology it took us several years
to figure that out by nineteen ninety
nine or so we'd figured it out and we
started doing some in-house development
work on a content management system at
the time there weren't too many of those
and we had to build ours ourselves as
the geekiest member of the editorial
team it fell to my shoulders to be one
of the managers of this project and it
turned into a classic software disaster
kind of a death march everything was
late and nothing worked right when we
deployed it everything broke once again
I found myself up all night and time
stopped but this time it was not much
fun and we charged into this incredibly
complex situation with little knowledge
of the history or the scope of the
problem and we were just paralyzed when
things went from bad to worse
excuse me I don't know how that slide
got in there now very sorry after the
dust settled I thought okay I'm ignorant
I don't know anything about this field
I've been a writer all my life the only
hands-on experience I had with
programming was back in ancient times I
don't know how to do this but somebody
must have figured it out right so I hit
the books and I pretty quickly realized
that in fact it's kind of an unsolved
problem and certainly not a simple
problem there are plenty of ideas out
there certainly and a lot of good ones
but nobody has really found the one true
way to develop software I thought this
could make a pretty interesting book so
I started working on dreamy encode in
earnest in about two thousand two and
this was a time you may recall after the
burst of the internet bubble when a lot
of people were and particularly in the
mainstream media which was my world were
sighing with relief they felt this is
great we no longer have to worry about
all of that computer stuff we can go
back and into our corners and not worry
about it and I knew that that was absurd
I was using the web more and more and
everyone around me was too I was
familiar with Bjorn Stroh straps line
our civilization runs on software and I
think it does but everywhere I look the
people making the software seem to be
having a hard time why was that now I've
always been a journalist and not a
theorist and i believe the telling
stories is one of the best ways to get
at the truth this is one of my favorite
story tellers Spalding Gray narrative is
the distillation of lived experience
into a memorable essence stories are
powerful and my first instinct as a
writer on this subject was to tell
stories I thought I would go out and
find maybe a half-dozen software
projects and tell their stories weave
them together into a book and use that
as a way to get at some of these
questions I had about that time it was
fall 2002 I read a column by Danville
more in the San Jose Mercury News and
told about a new project that Mitch cape
or who had created lotus 123 was a
launching and it was called Chandler it
was going to be a new model personal
information manager it was going to be
open source and peer-to-peer and help
people cope with information overload I
thought great this will be my first
project it was in the Bay Area I was in
the Bay Area wonderful I called cape or
up and I told him about the project and
he told me two things first thought
sounded like an interesting book idea
second his project was not going to be a
good subject because it was a typical he
said it's going to be driven by design
and most software projects or not and
also the organization that was building
it called the open source applications
foundation or OSAP was nonprofit and
that was a typical and I actually felt
that this made it even more interesting
for me too often it seems to me we view
the process of creating software solely
through the lens of business people
understand money better than they
understand programming so it's
understandable but the story of software
then becomes this tale that begins with
an IPO I'm sorry begins with raising
venture capital and then ends if you're
lucky with an IPO and the actual
programming work from the actual project
ends up being something that the writer
kind of averts our eyes from sort of
like the way old movies would handle sex
scenes you know you would see the
romantic couple embrace at one point and
then there would be this fast cut to the
next morning you weren't supposed to
look at this stuff and the creation of
software sometimes seems to be the same
way maybe writers think that it's just
too complex or maybe they think it's
they're worried that it's going to be
boring to their readers or they think it
doesn't matter because you know it's
just plumbing maybe you've heard that
phrase it's just plumbing who cares well
I wanted to fill in that blank and to
kind of write about the fashioning of a
piece of software in all its gory detail
I found it fascinating
thought the fact that Chandler was a
non-profit would actually give me the
chance to tell a different kind of
software story so Kate bore let me come
down to his office it was then in
belmont california and sit in on some
development meetings and before long i
found myself living and breathing
chandler in addition to the meetings
they were mailing lists and blogs then
there was a wiki that kept growing and
growing later there was cbs4 tracking
the code and tinder box for testing the
code and you could have CBS send you
email and you could keep up with the
wiki via email or RSS Chandler was
supposed to solve information overload
but for me it was causing it at that
point and I realized very quickly that
my original idea of having six different
projects and weaving it together was
insane it just wasn't going to work it
was too much for me to follow and it
would be too much to ask readers to
follow I also realized that this one
story would be enough to cover all the
topics that I knew I had to include
everything from frederick brooks in the
mythical man month to the history of
software disasters managing software
teams choosing tools and methodologies
communication between programmers and
designers the unfulfilled promise of
reusable code and most important of all
the problem of scheduling software
knowing how long things are going to
take the working on software really does
strange things to time when i first
visited the chandler team they were
saying that the product was going to be
out in a year so i immediately doubled
the number i said two years okay and i
got a book contract i had a timeline and
i figured i've left enough room in this
so that even if Chandler slips and slips
again it's all going to work okay but
after three years as the deadline for my
book began looming Chandler still had a
long way to go they kept scaling back
some of their ambitions and features in
an effort to speed things up but really
there was no way to say with any
reliability how long it was going to
take for them to finish
and that left me with something of a
dilemma right how how do I end a book
before the story is over and I'll let
those of you who decide to read the book
figure out that see how I did that but i
will say for those of you who've studied
any computer science that it has
something to do with recursion and
incompleteness and the halting problem
so it's natural to look at all this and
say well isn't this really just the
story of a product a project that did a
really bad job estimating its schedule
and the answer is yes it's true but it's
amazing how often that happens and it
doesn't only happen on relatively small
projects like Chandler it happens it's
kind of like the default on big
government projects right you know the
IRS and the FBI's problems probably
things that some of you know about and
you know maybe some of you in this room
have experienced some of this yourself
so when programmers hear about Chandler
and say what a bunch of losers you know
I'd never do that that could never
happen to me I say hold on you know
you've never worked on a project that
started with a great ambitions and then
found that it had to desperately scale
back in order to get something done in
your lifetime I don't know I think that
happens more often than not and it
certainly happens on the most
interesting projects that I encounter
now there isn't a lot of good hard data
about success and failure and software
project this report the Standish group's
chaos report is sort of the one thing
that people keep returning to started in
1995 that original report said that only
sixteen percent of IT projects are
successful they defined successful as on
time and on budget with all features and
functions as initially specified
thirty-one percent total failures the
remaining fifty-three percent project
challenged don't you love that phrase
challenged project which they said means
significantly over-budget or late or
reduced in scope now 2004 there's some
improvement but it's still not a great
picture some people have challenged this
study recently suggesting that there's a
problem because the people conducting
the study have
shared their methodology and that's a
good point but I think however you look
at it it's not good news for the field
now sometimes I talk to developers about
this they turn to me and say well you
know building complex things it's always
hard why do we expect software to be any
different well I do think there are
differences things that make software
unique so let me talk about some of them
from a relatively high altitude here
first of all software at heart is a
human construct its artificial one
question always comes up is why can't we
build software the way we build bridges
bridges are human constructs right but a
bridge really if you think about it is
built with these molecules that are part
of the natural world that obey
predictable laws of physics and natural
forces we know that they're going to
behave in certain ways software is made
of parts that we invented sitting and
sitting on top of other parts that we
invented all the way down in this in
some ways it's more like a work of
fiction than nonfiction we write it and
we make it all up now in his great book
the mythical man month Frederick Brooks
wrote the programmer like the poet works
only slightly removed from pure thought
stuff he builds his castles in the air
from air creating by exertion of the
imagination so software is almost pure
thought stuff a product of the
imagination there's this dream that
software engineering can evolve into a
mature discipline and take its rightful
place next to chemical engineering and
mechanical engineering and so on program
building could really become like bridge
building that sends me to this quote
from Peter Deutsche who said it's very
difficult to have real engineering
before you have physics and there isn't
anything even close to a physics for
software so we make it all up but it has
to work that's an interesting set of
conditions to try to meet now my
background is in
theater and one of the great plays about
the creative process is Ibsen's the
master builder which doesn't get
performed much anymore the lead
character is this aged architect and he
has this encounter with a mysterious
young woman from his past she comes to
him and keeps urging him to build
castles in the air but he's an engineer
so every time she says castles in the
air he responds yes but with solid
foundations now when I read this I would
scratch my head go what does this mean
and now that I've spent all this time
studying software I kind of think that
this is a great definition of what we're
trying to do when we build software you
need it's a castle in the air because
it's an imaginative product but it also
needs a solid foundation because it has
to work so that's one big area in which
i think software really is unique
another one is that it's incredibly hard
to visualize a complex program that has
practical consequences when we try to
create it we can't really touch it right
we have a hard time measuring it in any
useful way I don't lines of code doesn't
make a lot of sense to me feature points
it's usually apples and oranges right
unfinished versus done when is a piece
of software really done so measuring it
is really hard to we have a hard time
even talking about software and I'm
going to talk a lot more about that
problem of finding a common language a
little later so we gather around
whiteboards and we talk to each other
and we draw boxes and arrows and we
cross our fingers and we hope that the
boxes and arrows and words mean the same
thing to the other guy that they mean to
us now I know that today there is a
movement some people are calling it web
two point oh and in that corner the
developers are thinking well this is all
fine this is great but we do everything
on the web now and that solves all of
our problems and I agree with that up to
a point web based systems do solve one
set
problems and you probably know all these
already but I'll review them quickly so
end users are really bad system
administrators right so you manage their
data for them easy to apply patches and
updates because you're doing it all on
the server the browser solves all your
cross-platform issues you don't have to
worry about that you don't have to
reinvent the interface each time you do
a new application and the web keeps you
close to your users so you can get their
feedback and fix things quickly so
that's great hooray but moving to the
web also introduces a whole other set of
problems that we actually didn't have in
the old days the system depends on
network connectivity the browser
represents a whole new point of entry
for bad actors in malware and so we
turned to the New York Times and we see
a headline like attack of the zombie
computers but I love it we have privacy
concerns we're handing all of our data
over to somebody else we better trust
them and finally we do all of this stuff
within the browser and we think it's
really easy to do but we find it's
actually more complex and the more stuff
you do with these cool Ajax things in
the browser the more trouble you have
with oddball users like me who insist on
using strange browsers like opera
because it's less vulnerable to all of
that malware that's coming in through
the browser okay so more important than
any of these specific things though is a
larger point and this is really the
heart of the conclusion that I draw in
dreaming in code so I'm going to linger
on it a little bit I'm convinced as I
imagine some of you here are at least
that web based systems really are the
future right now and they are going to
be become where we move more and more of
our work that's possible precisely
because web based computing solve so
many of the problems of the previous
generation of software they let us do
things that we couldn't do before that's
great but as a result we'll ask them to
do more and more and eventually we'll
probably go too far we'll start out
amazed by the new capabilities of this
web-based software and then we'll end up
being made miserable by their
limitations and flaws and the software
industry will then move to
whatever its next phase will be I don't
think this dynamic is a function of
immaturity in the field I think its
inherent in the nature of the work of
the software field we had a version of
this discussion a few years ago some of
you may remember this guy Nick car came
out with an argument called IT doesn't
matter in the Harvard Business Review he
basically said that IT doesn't matter
because it won't provide your business
with a competitive edge everybody's
doing it now it's really just a holding
pattern where you have to accept that
you're going to spend a lot of money on
software but you should try to get away
with spending as little as possible I
think you know he was right up to a
point it's all true but only if you
believe that you fully mapped the
universe of what you expect your
software to do and i'm going to read one
of two short passages today from the
book here that addresses this
so I T doesn't matter as long as you
know in advance that the things you
expect software to accomplish for a
business accounting or workflow
automation inventory management you name
it are not going to change and that your
competition is using software to
accomplish the same set of things but of
all the capital goods in which
businesses invest large thumbs software
is uniquely mutable the gigantic
software packages for customer
relationship management enterprise
resource planning that occupy the lives
of the CTOs and CIOs of big corporations
may be cumbersome and expensive but they
are still just as much as the little
spreadsheets that Dan bricklin and Mitch
Cape are introduced to the world a
quarter century ago made of thought
stuff and so every piece of software
that gets used gets changed as people
decide they want to adapt it for some
new purpose no sooner do you introduce a
new system for employee surveys the
light bulb goes off over somebody's head
hey why can't we turn the same system
into a tool to schedule our company
parties all it will take is a few tweaks
and while they're at it maybe the
development team will add a nifty way
for me to catalog my music collection
then we could vote on the music that
we're going to play at those parties
have we really already discovered and
deployed all the usefulness and yes all
the frivolousness to that software
offers to believe so seems not only
arrogant but actively ignorant of recent
computing history by the mid-1980s for
instance business analysts were writing
off the entire personal computer
industry as mature and over the hill
just as the new wave of macintosh and
windows based computing was beginning to
build in the early 90s microsoft was
beginning to dominate the pc software
industry and the conventional wisdom was
that the entire business was
consolidating yet the internet was about
to kick it in new directions over the
over and over those who have bet that
there can be nothing new under the
technology industry sun have lost their
shirts to believe that we already know
all the possible uses for software is to
assume that the programs we already
possess satisfy all our needs and that
people are going to stop
teaching something better but as long as
we keep asking software software to
accomplish new things and solve new
problems fixing today's bugs still won't
protect us from tomorrow's crashes and
although software methodologies are very
helpful when you want to repeat a
success you can reproduce an outcome
only if you have one to start with if
you're exploring unknown territory best
practices might help you move a little
more quickly but they're not going to
point you to your destination software
development is often compared to the
construction industry but the analogy
breaks down in one respect even after
we've learned how to build structures to
solve particular problems sheltering a
family say or providing an appropriate
space for treating sick people we still
need to keep building more of those
structures however much I may like your
house I can't have it myself you're
already living there software doesn't
work that way once we know how to write
a program to balance a checkbook or
display a web page each additional copy
of the program costs nothing to produce
and the price you pay assuming you pay
at all is to reward the people who built
it who devised it not to construct your
copy therefore once somebody has written
a program that does exactly what you
needed to do it's always cheaper to buy
that software than to build something
from scratch time and time again however
we find that what we need or want is
just different enough from what's
available that we have no choice but to
write some new code at salon for
instance in the late 90s we realized we
needed to automate the way we published
our articles the most popular software
for content management at that time was
a big package called vignette had a
six-figure price tag a salesman from the
company visited our offices and
described it's hundreds of useful
features unfortunately we had no need
for most of them there were a couple of
things we needed to do and vignette
couldn't do them so we hired some
programmers to write our own system
instead now every writer about software
sooner or later ends up offering a law
under his own name so the time has come
for me with all due humility to do the
same I present Rosenberg's law software
is easy to make except when you want it
to do something new
now there is a corollary because there's
always a corollary the only software
that's worth making is software that
does something it ok I think you've
gotten a little bit of a taste of what
dreaming in code is about I should also
say that there are a lot of dogs in it
in my remaining time I want to focus on
one of the books themes and extend it in
a new direction the one heart of the
software problem is communication right
there's communication with the computer
which is what you're doing when you
program there's communication with the
user which is interface design then
there's also communication among the
people who create a program and that
last category I think is in many ways
the hardest and that's what I'm going to
focus on here when a group of people
work on a program together they have to
agree on a set of names names for
variables names for controls names for
everything like dill Bert's manager says
ninety percent of this job is figuring
out what to call stuff so here is my one
other passage that I'm going to read
this is all about the Chandler teams
wrestling with naming things as Oh saps
developers struggled to transform the
innovations in chandler from sketch to
functioning code they repeatedly found
themselves tripped up by ambiguity over
and over they would end up using the
same words to describe different things
tick item to the designers an item in
Chandler was anything a user thought of
as a basic piece of data a single email
an event on a calendar a task or a note
but the backend world of the Chandler
repository the database also had items
and its items were subtly but
substantially different from the front
ends items a repository item was a
single piece of information stored in
Chandler's database and in fact you
needed many of these repository items to
present a user of chandler with a single
user item like an email each attribute
of the user item the subject line or the
date sent the sender's address and so on
was a separate repository item at
different times in Chandler's evolution
arose to resolve this problem to
disambiguate the word item maybe the
term user item could always be
capitalized well that worked in writing
but not so well in conversation maybe
another term for one or the other type
of item could be adopted some of those
proposed like thing were even more
ambiguous and none of the proposals
stuck the Chandler universe was rife
with this sort of word overlap the
design team kept using the term data
model to refer to the list of
definitions of data types the user would
encounter along with all the attributes
associated with that data type for
example the data model would specify
every note had a date created an author
and a body text but to the developers
data model referred to a different and
more technical set of definitions that
they used to store and retrieve data at
the level of their code what the design
team called the data model was really in
the developers vocabulary the content
model then there was the problem with
the term scheduled task in the design
world a scheduled task meant an item on
a user's to-do list that had a date and
time assigned to it but for the
developers a scheduled task was
something Chandler itself had been told
to perform at a particular time like
download email or check for changes in
shared information or consider the term
event notification for the designers
this meant things like telling the user
new mail had arrived for the developers
an event with some change in the status
of a code object like a window closing
or a click on a menu item and
notification meant sending news of that
change to the other code objects cape or
would observe these little linguistic
train wrecks and shudder we need to
speak one language he would say we
should all speak Chandler ease we have
to fix the vocabulary finally Bryan
Skinner stepped forward to try to do
just that Skinner had joined OSAP as a
volunteer and help sort out the
subtleties of the data model now a
full-time programmer at OSF Skinner had
a knack for explaining developers speak
to the designers and design talked to
the developers when the group's talk
past each other he was often the one to
sort out the language why not he
proposed set up
anne-laure glossary on the wiki it would
provide a single authoritative easily
amended reference point for all the
terminology floating around the project
Skinner took up arms against the sea of
ambiguity he produced dozens of glossary
pages he he built a system for linking
to them from the rest of the wiki it was
a heroic effort but it didn't seem to
make much difference for one thing the
usage of the terms continue to change
faster than his wiki editing could keep
up more important to developers who were
already drowning in emails and bug
reports and wiki pages didn't seem to
pay much attention to the glossary and
the page is languished mostly unread the
glossary futility might have been
foreshadowed but the outcome of another
naming effort Skinner had been involved
in Oh SEFs Howard Street headquarters
had a half dozen conference rooms and
Kate board decided it would be useful
for them to have names osyth held a
contest and solicited proposals from the
staff Skinner suggested using names from
imaginary places he won the contest the
two main conference rooms became Avalon
and Arcadia the fanciful names captured
the spirit at oseph we're imagining new
worlds was on the collective to-do list
it was only later that everyone realized
what a bad idea was to have the names of
the most frequently used rooms begin
with the same letter no one could ever
remember which was which
so we can probably do a better job in
the area of human to human communication
but it's never going to be perfect there
will always be errors on that line
unlike in that world of network
protocols people are capable of finding
value in these errors we misunderstand
something and find something that we
actually like in her wonderful novel of
programming the bug by Ellen almond
which I heartily recommend she has this
great passage that riffs on the sea
command Malik now if you're a programmer
you know what it is it's a way to
allocate memory in a program if you're
not a programmer you hear this word
Malik it sounds like some kind of
biblical incantation of evil if you're
not an expert in a particular field
sometimes you just hear stuff
differently so one of my favorite albums
as a kid growing up in the 1970s was the
Grateful Dead's live dead it has this
song and it called v11 now I was reading
a lot of tolkien's at the time and if
you know the Lord of the Rings you know
there are all of these groups people who
have rings there's the 3 and the 5 and
the 7 for some reason they're all odd
numbers and so I heard the 11 and it
just it sounded magical to me I thought
it was this beautiful thing years later
I discovered what the song name really
meant it's a reference to the odd time
signature that they use in the song
instead of like a 44 march or a 340
waltz the song is in 11 8 so the title
was really just musical shop Talk and I
was projecting all of this poetry on to
it
my point is when we misunderstand one
another sometimes we please ourselves
and sometimes we can even come up with
useful new ideas we rip something out of
its original context and we find a new
path to some desired goal
misunderstandings can actually be viewed
not as bugs to be eradicated but as
accidents that can enrich us and we
should try to stay open to those
accidents The Wall Street Journal's Lee
Gomes recently ran a piece about the
early history of semiconductors and I
love this story I want to read just a
couple of sentences from it to you I'm
quoting Stanford professor thomas lee he
said William Shockley had been given a
very vague mission to find a solid
replacement for vacuum tubes starting in
the 1940s Shockley in a band of
stalwarts worked on the problem but they
failed repeatedly and spectacularly so
they switch gears and said what are the
reasons for our colossal ignorance one
of Shockley's employs a guy named john
bardeen designed a series of incredibly
brilliant experiments to diagnose their
failures but one of the experiments was
itself capable of amplification just
like the vacuum tubes they were trying
to duplicate so the initial invention of
the transistor was something they
stumbled on while they were trying to
diagnose their earlier failures to
invent a transistor so transistors
replaced vacuum tubes everywhere right
well not quite electric guitarists love
vacuum tubes because of the particular
warm kind of distortion that they create
distortion is another one of these happy
accidents its signal degradation right
it's a bug a good amplifier has very low
distortion only early in the history of
electric guitar playing link wray
discovered that distortion actually
sounds great and he started doing
something that later ray and Dave Davies
of the kinks did as well they took
pencils and poked them through the cones
of their speakers to get a better
distortion sound
so one man's signal degradation was
another's beauty and your bug can
sometimes be a breakthrough if you look
at it from a different angle now I don't
know if any of you saw the article came
out a week or two ago in a magazine
called baseline about the early
development of myspace but it's
fascinating it talks about you know all
the problems they had in getting myspace
going and if you know myspace you
probably know that one of its most
popular features is the fact that the
service lets you make your page be as
ugly as you want it to be and it turns
out that this feature was actually a bug
the developers had forgotten or failed
to put in the filtering to filter out
the formatting that the users could put
in when they did there when they input
their content and then eventually of
course they figured out that they should
not fix that bug so the old joke that's
you know it's not a bug it's a feature
what if that's not a joke what if it's
wisdom of some kind the x and y know the
musician and producer says he doesn't
read the manual for new devices when he
gets them in the studio he wants to
figure out all the different things they
can do not just the things that the
people who created them wanted you to
use them for in essence he's taking
tools and products that were offered up
as scientific entities and treating them
as artistic media now one theme of
dreamy encode is this whole question is
programming really an art or a science
it's one of these questions that will
never be resolved plainly it's some of
both I think you know has something
useful to tell us about this he calls it
inos second law I don't know what the
first one is science is the conversation
about how the world is culture is the
conversation about how else the world
could be and how else we could
experience it he goes on to say science
wants to know what can be said about the
world what can be predicted about it art
likes to see which other worlds are
possible to see how it would feel if it
were this way instead of that way as
such art can give us the practice and
agility to
think and experience in new ways
preparing us for the new understandings
of things that science supplies so
software is plainly right in the middle
it's sort of a bridge between art and
science when it works it takes a little
bit of a newly imagined world of
possibility and injects it back into the
predictable scientific world as it is I
think that's pretty important
undertaking it's certainly more than
just plumbing and it's worth the effort
to keep trying to do better even as we
know that will probably keep falling
short that's the end of my presentation
I'd love to hear questions and comments
from you all because I'm sure that a lot
of you know more about the subject than
I do thank you yes please 11 big
software development things that didn't
did not did not slip schedule and that
was a you 2,000 bug fix which worked
remarkably smooth you can you comment
the year 2000 bug fix um yes well is so
uh it was it was a predictable that we
it was an event with a clear deadline
and we don't really know well one of the
interesting things I wrote about that at
the time I interviewed a guy named Eddie
Jordan who had predicted great disaster
and it's one of those cases where we
know that a lot of work got done in
advance and we know that there were no
big disasters what we don't know and can
never know is had we not done that work
would there have been big disasters and
I don't know enough about it to say but
there was a lie I view that as sort of a
great act of prevent you know of
foresight and and preventive care it's
the kind of thinking that we should be
employing more in a lot of other areas
like the environment I think but at
least you know the software field kind
of kept it's a house in order there so
yes I think that's a good example please
the bridge building
ursinus I'm sorry the bridge building
metaphors is one computer scientists
talk about quite a bit and the last time
I recall talking with somebody about
that they offered also this twist on it
we don't have generally people going
around trying to blow up all our bridges
fried certainly if software is like
bridges and we're building these things
you know we've also got to do a lot more
to defend them at least so that so in a
way though then Britain the bridge
building metaphor we you know we could
extend it and talk about you know
military hardware so in in in on the
battlefield there are other people going
around trying to blow things up and of
course in a battlefield environment you
are indeed much more focused on security
but i would say that even if you take
that that aspect out of the picture even
if you say you know you imagine a
hypothetical world in which there aren't
bad actors trying to break your software
before any of that was really the case
back really before the internet was
popular when the problems with software
were really limited mostly to our
desktops we still have lots of problems
so i'm not sure that that it's a further
layer of complication to the problem i
think rather than you know is something
that changes the picture about software
is the environment means
so you didn't really talk about that but
when software was in the local area
network and there was a buffer overflow
that was not exploitable and once now
same piece of software exactly the same
piece of software change the environment
so just like you're saying you know the
bug might be a feature you know in one
environment the bug has been isolated
and the other its exploitable so I think
the other aspect of software is that it
is connected through physical devices to
the real world and in one environment
that software can be tamed in the other
it can be exploited and that environment
changes all the time so that this piece
of software which was had a flaw that
was simply a you know minor issue when
you move that into a network environment
it suddenly becomes a security problem
but we also you know we we know that the
environments are going to keep changing
so we can't you know we can't sort of
turn the clock back in any way we just
have to kind of deal with that and in a
way I mean I think that if you think
about other fields if you think about
architecture well if the worst
predictions of climate change are
accurate and we see sort of the worst
case scenarios there a lot of buildings
are going to face stresses and problems
that were not part of the original
environment that they were designed for
and that's going to be a big big deal
I'm sorry
yeah so you were with the Chandler team
for a while I think and you've discussed
some of the problems that they've had
what can we learn from from their
failures to show Shiva you want but I
did yes it's a good question and I I
with dreaming in code I deliberately set
out not to write a book that would offer
explicit lessons because I felt there
are a lot of books out there already
many of them are very good they're
mostly written by people with a lot more
experience than me and I didn't want to
you know kind of pretend to some level
of you know hands-on expertise that I
don't have so that's you know the the
book is really designed to be a story
that you can read and draw your own
conclusions from however that said I'm
perfectly happy to tell you that you
know the lesson that I came away from
and the lesson that I'm trying to apply
back at my job is don't start with you
know a huge set of ambitions in multiple
directions pick something small this is
the same thing that linna's Torvald says
I quote him in the book and I think it's
the same thing that pretty much you know
a lot of people same conclusion that
people arrive at from multiple
directions you start small and you build
incrementally and you keep your gaze
focused you know reasonably on the next
goal and you build your schedule around
that and then you have the opportunity
to correct course because you can see
how far you got in a certain period of
time if you start with a very large set
of goals I mean I you know I wasn't here
and some of you were so I don't know
everything about the Vista the Longhorn
story but I know that I it was happening
at the same time as the Chandler project
and I was following it from a distance
and I read a lot of the stuff about the
win FS and it sounded like a wonderful
thing like I wanted that it sounded like
you know it could really help but I also
wondered I thought wow this is a very
ambitious thing it's a hard thing to do
can they do that and do all these other
things at the same
time and indeed it turned out that that
didn't happen so you know I i think it's
it's a lesson that seems to hold at all
different levels of software work at
salon we've got two or three developers
at Chandler they had two dozen at
Microsoft there are thousands and I
think that it applies that on all those
levels first you so there you're a
number of stuff done these qualities
good estimation concession be the right
things and somehow properly use the
methodologies that they should be using
or do they cross the cross we miss you
something I think um it's very hard to
say because everyone this is was a group
of experienced developers who they were
not following a particular methodology
but they were certainly knowledgeable
about many methodologies and I think
part of it is that this was a you know a
unique environment where there wasn't a
constraint of a certain amount of money
that was going to run out because it was
sort of a self-funded thing and a group
of developers who had been given a set
of goals that may have just been too
much and so over time they evolved what
became a very effective scheduling
system but it took them you know that
didn't happen for roughly two to three
years you know and they got to a point
once they had found that they weren't
making progress the way they wanted to
that they started doing better but at
the beginning it was very freeform so
if you go project learning you have a
deadline of next Christmas and then
that's your operational diamond you have
to figure out something that's true yeah
it was not it was it didn't have a
deadline of next Christmas but it had a
stated kind of it had publicly stated at
the beginning of they said a year so
it's different from a deadline is
because it's it's not working there
isn't somebody who's going to cut off
the funding or shut it down or something
if it's not there so in that sense not a
deadline but on the other hand it
certainly had the pressure to to try to
do it you know I I I you know I cute i
quote andy hertzfeld as one of the
developers as guy from the original
Macintosh team and he every time I would
sort of talk to him about different
projects I would engage with him hear
some stories and things he would say
every project is different and you know
I think my experience in talking to
people is that's true that there's an
impulse that people have that they say I
know what a best practice is here I know
what I should be doing but there are
these unique circumstances this time and
because of those unique circumstances I
just can't do that thing that I know is
right and I hear that I in my job I Ivan
maybe some of you encounter that in your
work here at Microsoft my experiences
it's pretty Universal there are
certainly discipline teams everywhere
that avoid that and either through
experience through good leadership
whatever reason that you know they say
no you know well we may be unique but
we're not so unique that we shouldn't be
doing these things that will help us get
to where we're going and that's real
discipline and if you have that or if
you have a team leader who's got that or
if you have that yourself that's very
valuable yes
because going back to this previous
question there a lot of great open
source projects like the Apache
Foundation's projects which don't really
have a consistent strip schedule but
they do ship when they ship it's pretty
good quality you know so I'm interested
in answering your your musings about
that so if you chew on that forbidden
open-source up at Chandler was a little
bit different because most open source
projects start with a code base right
and there is code of some kind and then
one developer maybe starts at another
few developers kind of join up after the
code is posted and contribute things and
it grows kind of organically and
Chandler was interesting in that it was
technically open source in that from the
very beginning they were posting their
code and it was openly available you
could always download it so it was open
source in that sense but it was not
functioning with the open source
development model in that the group of
people creating it was really closer to
a start-up team it was you know a bunch
of developers working together mostly in
one office although over time they began
to have some people working from a
distance and so it it's taken them they
are at this point finally beginning up
in the project beginning to have the
occasional contribution of code from
outside there's one that that I
Chronicle late in the book and so
there's the beginning of that but I know
that the people I was writing about
throughout knew that they were
frustrated that they hadn't reached that
point they knew that they had to get the
product to a certain level of value
before other developers would commit to
contributing to it the phrase in the
open source world from Eric Raymond's
paper about the Cathedral in the bazaar
is applause applause abell promise you
don't have to have a finished product
but you have to have a plausible promise
that the developer will will find the
product useful
and we'll find his contribution to be a
value and it took them it's taken a long
time to get there at Chandler yes please
you mention a lot of similarities
between software and bridge building and
their own article world didn't end there
you know bridge building a particular
tutorials for be over budget and late so
in that sense there are two questions I
want to ask first as do you really think
that problems that were saying software
are you know different from problems
that we're seeing in the real world
building and architecture and growth in
built in two thousand four years and
second is you think there is because you
know am being able to fix the building
from 4,000 years dirty there's a hope in
software that move
so the first part is you know aren't the
first question then is isn't building
software and building bridges really
very similar and we mess up when we
build bridges to and we're over budget
and all that and that's true but the end
we have disastrous certainly in bridge
building to we had a lot more of them in
the 19th century than we do today but i
still find in my research that the the
big difference is that bridges people
have an instinctive understanding of the
physical nature of the work they know
that you have you know before you can
there's a sequencing to the work that's
necessary that even the non-expert
understands you've got to put the
pilings in you know before you can put
the girders up before you can put the
roadbed on it's just kind of obvious
that that the sequencing is is going to
be a certain way and you also know that
once you pour concrete that's a really
bad time to decide that you're going to
have a new design although interestingly
in I live in the Bay Area and one of the
things that was happening while I was
writing this book is the Bay Bridge is
being rebuilt and lo and behold they
built half of it and then had a big
argument with the state legislature
about whether they should redesign it at
that point so so that's kind of funny
and and maybe to your point um so I do
think I think that there are aspects in
which the two really are very similar
but there are a few aspects of software
that that do make it unique and do I
think we'll ever get there I don't my
gut feeling is no is that what will
happen is that we achieve a level of
reliability and stability at a layer of
software and then we forget about it I
mean there's stuff that we don't
generally think about today that 30
years ago or 40 years ago was what
programmers had to deal with whether
it's you know the Machine level or you
know higher up there's this sequencing
this this piling on of layers that
happens and we're always working on the
next layer and that's the layer that
we're kind of fighting with and having
difficulty with and
I don't see that process changing it
seems to me that's the nature of
software as long as we're writing
software we're going to be piling these
layers on and will always be kind of
wrestling with whatever the newest one
is I hope I mean I might be wrong and if
I am wrong that'll be a good thing but
this is my conclusion from the work I've
done anyone else yes you see is this
thing just going to flame out and go I'm
examined er if the similar story
couldn't have been written about you
know the Mozilla Foundation a few years
ago and was like oh this thing's
collapsing it's a disaster and then you
know they sort of focused on Firefox and
it took off and it's great right so
that's precisely the comparison that
that I used in the book you know people
come to me and say well you know you've
written this book about this failed
project and I actually don't view it as
a failed project certainly a project
that has had you know enormous
difficulties and delays and there's no
you no sugarcoating that but with
Mozilla I we ran articles in salon that
said you know Mozilla they're gone
forget it they've started with a lot of
enthusiasm and then after a year or two
a lot of people left and they made some
decisions to rewrite the whole
presentation engine or whatever it was
and they did you know and people
criticize that it took them years and
they were written off and now they're
really you know sort of contributing
something that people are enthusiastic
about again question yeah especially
relative bridgeville because the rewrite
was done for a very specific reason
which is an architecture participation
right as you design these things to be
increasingly modular then you actually
engage the community to come in
start developing code so the office has
gone through the same restructure from
one point 0 to 2 point 0 so this is is
that there's actually some fairly deep
stuff here that I beard stood in having
somebody write a book about and explore
like how does the architecture
interrelate with the ability of the open
source project to be successful so the
better the better architected the
application is to allow people to
contribute the more likely that's going
to happen but getting to that point is
arduous yeah witnesses x server right
the rapid server a couple years ago with
rewritten in version 7 from programmer
would have to know almost all the code
base to modify any of it effectively to
because module system where you just
know the little bit that you knew and
effectively how to integrate and do a
little bit of you know a little bit of
built testing and then you could go and
since then you know enormous changes in
length desktop sense
it's just about middle yeah well
Chandler I think um it as I understand
it and I'm not an expert the
architecture of it from the beginning
has been as modular as it ought to be
and the you know the issue has been more
just getting enough of it in place that
a developer could see why they would
would want to be involved personally I'm
not writing it off at all i'm still kind
of eagerly expecting hoping that you
know they're there is going to be
something there that i can use there was
a vision in the project for a chandler
to be more than just a personal
information manager but really to be a
free-form information manager that you
could adapt it and they have some cool
little kind of almost nash up style
plugins that let you pull thing pull
photos in from flickr and bookmarks in
from delicious and use chandleraz this
sort of information center for
cataloguing and organizing all this
stuff that you might have on the
computer you know similar way to that
when FS was was going to the you know
that what that promise was and so I want
that as a user and I'm still I'm not
certainly writing Chandler off as
something that someday might help us do
that yes baby off subject but I
understand the most complicated software
around these telephone exchanges and I
never could figure that out because they
were built to replace an Undertaker's
wife and you don't do that the telephone
exchange is that's the most complex
software code I don't know anything
about that no it's I sounds like an
interesting thing to look up although I
guess it's kind of gradually being I
mean telephone exchanges are sort of
going to become a thing of the past
right with with IP telephony and
at some point you say with your foot
type to fool your mom I'm not I'm not an
expert so you know yes on the buck but
the day yeah what do i do read it yeah
yeah the feedback I got I've gotten to
date from the people on the project they
felt that it was a fair portrait you
know nobody felt that it was I had been
inaccurate or unfair to them so I'm
pleased about that I think that they you
know clearly when when Mitch invited me
in I know that he was very optimistic
that this project was going to be
speedier and less trouble than it turned
out to be and to his credit he never
turned to me and said you know what I
think you better get out of here and I
give him a huge credit for that for
sticking to his commitment to opening
his project to that kind of transparency
and you know will will the jury's still
out and Chandler isn't you know over so
you know I think that the the spotlight
that the book shines on Chandler well
it's giving them some attention now and
in April they're going to have what
they're calling the preview release its
kind of their next big thing we'll see
what that's like and maybe the book will
will give them some something to point
to and say well that was what that was
then and this is now all right well
thank you very much